james bond has a massive franchise of 25
films where he saves the world time and
time again with so much violence
villains and vengeance it can be hard to
keep track grab your popcorn as we
unravel 007's entire filmography from
connery to craig i admire your luck
mr
bond
james bond
in the first film in the bond series dr
no bond travels to jamaica to
investigate the death of the mi6 station
chief bond's subsequent investigation
which included multiple attempts on his
life led him to crab key and a
radioactive area guarded by a dragon
which turned out to be a tank with a
flamethrower attached there bond and his
companion honey ryder discovered the
lair of dr julius no a scientist who'd
been recruited by the evil organization
known as spectre or special executive
for counter-intelligence terrorism
revenge and extortion noah's plan
involved using his advancements in
radiation to disrupt the upcoming
launches of the mercury space program
with ryder's help bond is able to
sabotage the effort kill no and destroy
his lair his success in stopping dr no
led to a vow of vengeance from spectre
leadership that would haunt bond for
years dr no also introduced a key bond
ally cia agent felix lighter who would
assist him in future missions from
russia with love introduced more spectre
leadership including the mysterious
number one and featured assassins
attempting to lure bond to his death by
stealing a russian cryptographic device
though several spectre killers pursued
him bond was able to both free the
device from spectre control and kill his
assassins the film also introduced
bond's beloved equipment master q
in goldfinger bond shifted focus from
spectre to arik goldfinger a gold
obsessed megalomaniac who with the help
of smuggled nerve gas planned to
detonate a dirty bomb in fort knox to
make the u.s supply of gold useless this
would increase the value of goldfinger's
own personal gold board and plunge the
world into economic chaos bond was able
to thwart goldfinger's plans with the
help of the pilot plus galore goldfinger
also introduced another key part of the
bond mythos his aston martin spy car
complete with ejecting passenger seat
thunderball featured the return of
spectre and a plot led by emilio largo
number two in the organization to hijack
a pair of nuclear bombs from nato and
hold the world hostage with the help of
largo's former mistress domino bond was
able to infiltrate largo's home to kill
him you only lived twice featured
another encounter with spectre including
the organization's mysterious leader
ernst blofeld with the help of the head
of the japanese secret service bond went
undercover to find spectre's secret
volcano lair where a plot to covertly
start world war three was underway with
numerous japanese operatives fighting
alongside him bond defeated blofeld but
didn't kill him
on her majesty's secret service is the
only bond film to star george lazenby as
double07 and it's also one of the most
consequential films in the franchise in
that film bond is tracking blowfeld when
he meets teresa tracy to vincenzo who he
began to romance after saving her from a
suicide attempt tracy's father the head
of a massive european crime syndicate
encouraged the romance and bond agreed
to keep seeing tracy in exchange for
information about blofeld bond's
investigation into the head of spectre
ultimately led him to the swiss alps
where blofeld established a clinic
claiming to cure people of their
allergies in reality blowfeld had
brainwashed 12 women to be angels of
death who would become biological
weapons which sabotaged the food supply
of the world blonde's boss m agreed to
blowfeld's ransom terms but because
blowfeld captured tracy vonn decided to
mount an attack on the facility anyway
bond with the help of tracy's father and
his allies was able to thwart blowfeld's
plan but failed to capture the head of
spectre when they reunited bond and
tracy were married but the union was cut
tragically short blofeld and his
operative irma blunt staged a drive-by
shooting on vaughn's parked car and
while double07 survived his new bride
was killed tracy's deaths would continue
to haunt bond for years
diamonds are forever marked the final
time in the eon series that bond would
be played by sean connery and featured
007 battling blofeld yet again this time
the head of spectre was revealed as the
mastermind behind a diamond smuggling
ring and the construction of a
diamond-encrusted satellite laser that
could detonate nuclear weapons from
space blofeld planned to auction the
satellite off to the highest bidder but
bond was once again able to stop him
live and let die marked the beginning of
the roger moore era of bond an era that
featured no major spectre stories and
instead relied on a slightly more
standalone style in that film bond
traveled to the caribbean island of san
monica to investigate the deaths of
three different mi6 operatives in less
than 24 hours there he uncovered a plot
by the island's leader dr kananga to
distribute free heroin in a chain of
restaurants and thus increase drug
addiction and therefore drug sales
around the world the whole operation was
disguised by a cloud of voodoo based
terror to prevent locals from asking too
many questions with the help of
kananga's advisor miss solitaire bond
was able to stop the operation
i know you
oh no
you're that secret agent that english
secret agent from england
in his next two adventures bond would
encounter several different kinds of
killers who would challenge his place as
the world's deadliest secret agent in
the man with the golden gun bond
received a golden bullet from the
titular assassin a reclusive millionaire
named francisco scaramenga though empold
bond back from official business double
07 set out to track down scaramanga
himself and ultimately learned that
skaramanga had stolen a device that
could change the future of energy
production and disrupt the world economy
the two battled on scaramanga's remote
island home near china and bond
ultimately defeated the man with the
golden gun the spy who loved me saw bond
investigating a series of vanished
submarines owned by both british and
soviet navies he was forced to team up
with soviets by anya amasova and the two
uncovered a plot by billionaire
scientist carl stromberg to start a
nuclear war using the submarines bond
and amasova were able to infiltrate
stromberg's underwater lair where he
planned to restart civilization after
world war iii was fought and stopped
nuclear missiles from reaching new york
and moscow the spy who loved me also
introduced one of bond's most memorable
opponents the metal-toothed assassin
known only as jaws
over the course of his next four movies
bond would traverse the world while
dealing with everything from mad
scientists to power hungry russian
generals in moonraker bond teamed up
with cia agent holly goodhead to stop
industrialist hugo drax from wiping out
the world's human population via deadly
nerve gas and starting a new perfect
civilization from a secret space station
and for your eyes only bond teamed up
with a vengeful young woman to stop a
secret british targeting computer from
falling into soviet hands the cold open
features bond visiting his wife's grave
and battling a slightly disguised
version of blofeld before killing him in
reality blofeld had been removed from
more era bond films for legal reasons
and this was the franchise's
tongue-in-cheek way of addressing that
in octopus he bond again faced scheming
soviet generals this time he teamed up
with the unlikely title ally the
enigmatic leader of a cult of women who
ran a circus troop to stop a nuclear
bomb plot that would lead to soviet
dominance in western europe then in a
view to a kill bond traveled to san
francisco to stop the mad business titan
max zorin from flooding silicon valley
to secure his own monopoly on the future
of microchips each time bond was able to
win in the end
in 1987 the bond series passed into the
hands of new star timothy dalton who
starred in two very different bond films
to close out the decade in the living
daylights bond was once again swept up
in cold war schemes this time in the
form of a kgb defector who sought 007's
protection when the defecting agent went
missing bond began investigating and was
swept into a web of lies that involved a
cellist a renegade arms dealer and a
defection that may have been staged all
along license to kill brought a more
personal approach to bond's work and
re-teamed him with his old cia friend
felix lighter when the head of a drug
cartel ordered a revenge hit on lighter
severely injuring him and killing his
wife in the process bond set out for
revenge when em trying to reign him in
bond wouldn't budge and so his license
to kill was revoked as a rogue spy with
a little help from q bond journeyed to
central america to seek revenge and
destroy a drug cartel in the process
[Music]
beg your pardon forgot to knock
after a six-year gap james bond returned
for the beginning of the pierce brosnan
era with goldeneye a film that heavily
relied on the idea that bond was the
product of a bygone age dealing with new
threats in that film he dealt directly
with the fallout from the end of the
cold war in the form of his former
partner double06 who'd faked his death
to transition to leading a criminal
organization which in turn planned to
use a satellite emp device to crash
britain's economy in tomorrow never dies
bond went toe-to-toe with the
manipulation of the media as he battled
media mogul elliot carver carver plans
to start a phony war between britain and
china by creating news meant to inflame
tensions with the help of a deadly
stealth ship and some clever technology
in the world is not enough bond dealt
once again with the fallout from the
cold war battling an ex-kgb agent and an
oil heiress he'd once considered a
friend as they attempted to steal soviet
plutonium to create a bomb to enhance
their own oil interests in brosnan's
final bond film die another day double o
seven's list of modern threats grew to
include north korea as he battled the
korean colonel who disguised himself as
a british billionaire as part of a
scheme to destroy the demilitarized zone
between north and south korea starting
the korean war all over again no file
shows no kills
and it takes two
with the beginning of the daniel craig
era of bond eon productions decided to
do something new and completely rebooted
the bond timeline though judy dench
stayed on for this era of the series zem
she was the only real holdover from the
brosnan days all of bond's other allies
were recast and bond himself was
depicted as a much younger operative he
gains his double o status in the cold
open of casino royale by killing two
people as part of a mission the bulk of
casino royale involves bond
investigating the funding of terrorism
through the dangerous banker known as
the shift with the help of british
treasury agent vesper lind as the pair
dug deeper into the shift's money and
where it was going they were able to
gain a key victory via a high-stakes
poker game but the ship retaliated by
kidnapping them both
now
the ship was killed by an enigmatic man
known as mr white and while bond was
able to reunite with vesper he also
discovered she could be a double agent
as bond attempted to stop vesper's
treachery he was attacked by white's men
vesper ultimately sacrificed herself and
her supposed betrayal was revealed to be
part of a deal she made with white save
bond's life vesper's death would
continue to haunt bond for much of the
story that followed and he began his
quest for vengeance by tracking down
white
bond's capture and subsequent
interrogation of mr white revealed the
existence of a criminal group known as
quantum the primary villains of quantum
of solace the film saw bond battling the
shadowy group as it attempted to seize
control of bolivia's water supply to
create a monopoly bond ultimately
triumphed and in the process was able to
seemingly let go of his grief over
vesper's death skyfall brought a more
personal mission to the fore as bond
returned to mi6 after a self-imposed
exile when the organization's
headquarters was bombed by an unknown
attacker working with them who faced
pressure from her superiors to retire
bond discovered the mastermind was
ex-mi6 agent raul silva silva worked for
m in the years before bond came along
until she disavowed him and left him to
be tortured by chinese agents leaving
him disfigured and eager to seek revenge
it's not very comfortable is it
are you going to complain the whole way
i'll go on then eject me see if i can
with silva's grip on mi6 seemingly too
tight to shake bond and m retreated to
scotland to bond's ancestral home
skyfall once there they prepared for an
assault with the help of the house's
groundskeeper though they were able to
fight off silva's men and eventually
kill silva himself em died from her
wounds after the battle leaving bond to
mourn another important woman in his
life spectre began with bond
investigating a lead left for him by him
against the wishes of the new m bond
persisted with his investigations
despite a new privatization effort that
led to the shutdown of the double o
program and found a shadowy organization
led by a man named franz oberhauser
further investigation revealed that mr
white still alive after the events of
quantum of solace was somehow connected
to this organization and that oberhauser
was supposed to have died decades
earlier teaming with mr white's daughter
madeline swann bond discovered that all
of his previous enemies including the
schiff members of quantum and raul silva
could all be tied back to the
organization known as spectre even the
privatization at mi6 which included a
new global surveillance effort was a
spectre-backed attempt to thwart
counter-terrorism agents then it got
worse after capturing bond oberhauser
revealed that his true name was ernst
stavro blofeld and that he'd known bond
as a boy after bond's parents died
oberhauser's father took bond in and
began to look at him with such favor
that young franz decided to seek revenge
he killed his father faked his death and
devoted his life to a massive criminal
enterprise that he ultimately turned on
bond this massive personal vendetta
decades in the making culminated with
bond capturing but not killing blofeld
leaving him free to return for future
sequels
bond emerged from the film spectre with
blofeld in prison and madeleine swann on
his arm and decided it was time to step
away from mi6 in favor of a trip with
his lover hoping to build a future with
madeline bond opted to visit vesper's
grave in italy and let her go once and
for all when he visited the gravesite
though it was revealed to be a specter
trap which bond immediately blamed on
madeleine though he was willing to get
her out of harm's way he wasn't willing
to attempt to mend fences yet again
feeling that he'd had enough of
betrayal's bond put madeleine on a train
intending to leave her behind forever
and entered retirement from mi6 done
with the life of a hard fighting spy he
retreated to jamaica to live out the
rest of his days in solitude but as it
always goes with james bond the past
still had a way of catching up
five years after bond left madeleine and
retired from mi6 his old friend felix
lighter tracked him down with a new
mission a dangerous new weapon dubbed
heracles had fallen into the hands of a
terrorist known as saffin bond
investigated and discovered heracles was
an mi6-packed weapon a nanobot cloud
that could kill anyone whose dna was
placed into its targeting system as bond
discovered this he also witnessed saffin
orchestrate a plan to use heracles to
murder every member of spectre and lost
felix during the mission furious bond
turned to blofeld now in prison and the
only surviving member of spectre as he
attempted to interrogate blofeld bond
inadvertently killed him as the heracles
nanobots were in his bloodstream but
coded to kill blofeld that left one more
person with knowledge of saturn
madeleine who'd met the villain as a
child
desperate to stop heracles which had the
potential to kill millions bond sought
out his former lover and found more than
he bargained for bond found madeleine at
her childhood home in scandinavia and
learned that in the five years since
they'd last seen each other she'd given
birth to a daughter who she named
matilde madeline and mathilde were
captured and taken to a secluded island
where safin held court at a poison
garden with the help of q and nomi his
replacement as agent 07 bond followed
saf into the island with the goal of
saving madeline and matild and
destroying heracles
bond and nomi managed to infiltrate
saffon's island and made a terrifying
discovery they had scaled up production
on heracles and were preparing to use it
on countless victims around the world
racing against time bond managed to
rescue madeleine and mathilde and get
them to safety then began figuring out
how to stop heracles the only solution
was to destroy the entire island which
could only be done via airstrike bonds
stayed behind to open the blast doors on
saffin's facility to ensure the entire
supply of heracles would be destroyed
only to encounter safin one more time in
the process as a parting gift before
dying safin tainted the dormant heracles
nanobots in bond's system with the coded
dna of madeline and mathilde ensuring
that he could never touch either of them
without killing them confronted with his
own death bond contacted madeline who
told him matild was indeed his daughter
the airstrike missiles rained down as
bond looked out over the ocean putting
an end to daniel craig's incarnation of
the character just as he learned he'd
left a legacy in the world beyond
violence check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about james bond are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you